folks how we doing you know I got some
good news today all right and we're
going to do a video that we've done
before but just the current version of
it all right the 2023 Edition and I say
it's good news because a lot of folks
are sending me emails inquiries messages
whatever it is what should I get on my
new tractor what options should I
consider which new tractor should I get
comparisons this that the other thing
right which is great and the reason I
say that is because you know you always
get Doom and Gloom in the media right
the sky is falling it's easy to fall
into that trap of you know we're heading
to a recession and and this that the
other thing but the reality is is that
there's still strong demand and it's not
demand like there was when it was
through the roof that was unsustainable
for the last couple of years but as a
business owner myself
I want to see what is actually happening
not just what I'm being told is
happening out in some little Fairytale
Land and so the reality is a lot of
folks are out shopping for tractors
still
um and even in the Auto industry right
and part of this is probably due to
backups at other points in production
but Ford set a record smashed it sold
almost 100 000 Super Duties
it's either October November I think it
was November they set that record almost
a hundred thousand Super Duties in one
month
those things are like I don't know
what's an average price tag on a Super
Duty 70 grand
a lot of them go for more than that so
that's pretty crazy anyway so what I
want to talk about today and
and give you guys perspective all you
folks out there shopping for a new
tractor maybe it's going to be your
first tractor maybe you've already had a
tractor it's time to upgrade but I had
two more emails just yesterday or the
day before that were the same thing one
was going to buy a brand new tractor he
was decided between the 4066 and a
50-65e or four Series in a 5 series he
settled on the 4066 wanted to know what
he should get on it when he's building
that out new the other gentleman was
upgrading he had a 30 33r wanted to
upgrade to a 4 Series uh his local
dealer that he was working with had a
40-44r and a 4052r some differences
there but the same price point almost
older the 4052 was older 200 hours the
4044 was a 2022 in like 20 hours or
something but the same price and so
really this conversation applies to new
or used but the idea behind it is
getting a tractor or purchasing it set
up the way that you want and a lot of us
don't because we don't know any better
and there are solutions you can get
afterwards that will set it up the way
that you want but they can cost more
money we do have partners that you can
save money buying through as well and so
really this applies to new or used
tractors you just want to have it set up
the right way and in a sense that's
really why we had the summit tractor
here behind us so I'll tell you some
more about that too as we go through
this but this applies to Kubota John
Deere Mahindra coyote LS whatever brand
you're shopping the same Common Sense
approach applies all right so for some
of you folks out there that you've seen
these videos before
let me know do you agree with what I
said did you follow the advice did you
go a different direction what worked for
you if there's something I don't mention
today that you think's worth getting
point it out because that's important
information for folks to know all right
so we'll start at the front of the
tractor move our way back and so we're
going to start out with the front end
loader all right right up here the
business end and you've seen the
interchangeability forks a pusher a
bucket a grapple a bale spear
probably other tools as well there are
other tools I just can't think of them
you need to have a quick attached system
and be that the John Deere quick attach
which is only going to be on a John
Deere tractor or they call it hook and
pin as well everybody else will have a
skid steer quick attach two levers that
you can pull and release your bucket
there's going to be some funky systems
out there too Yanmar and some of the
certain series of Yanmar have their own
specialized quick attach we don't sell
anything that's the end mark quick
attach out of the gate we can special
order it and we're talking about maybe
having a stump bucket version that is
Yanmar quick attach but just get a skid
steer quick attached just just get a
skid through a quick attach just like
the summit has on it you'll be good to
go okay just moving just behind it
you're going to see a couple of outlets
right there those are going to be third
function or diverter outlets and they're
going to be positioned up front because
they're going to connect to a grapple or
an angling a hydraulic angling snow plow
and you're going to need that third
function to operate those kinds of tools
and so the summit tractor does come
standard with that third function up
front but most companies out there do
not there's going to be a couple here
and there but most manufacturers don't
so you're going to have to add that on
take a look for the option it's not
uncommon for it to be 1500 or 2000
you'll find a dealer here and there
that'll be a bit less than that as well
if you need to get an aftermarket
solution go to Summit Hydraulics website
you can get a DIY solution
do-it-yourself at home it's going to be
like a fraction of the cost you can save
five percent with code GWT okay so one
more item on the loader all right so
this version here is a self-leveling
loader or a mechanical self-leveling
loader an MSL mechanical self leveling
is what that means and so as you raise
up and down like if you have pallet
Forks the best example right if you want
to lift a pallet up you want to keep
that level the whole time no matter how
high or low you're raising it and the
self leveling option helps do that it
just the extra brackets and the magic
and the geometry out here gets that done
it is an extra cost you know there's
some other benefits to that as well if
you're using a a pusher or a bucket for
example 2 and you want to keep that that
level all the time and you're raising
your loader up and down you don't have
to worry about the curl roll function
just up and down will help keep it level
two now I can make a case either way you
know on getting a non-self leveling or a
mechanical self-leveling loader there's
benefits to both and there's times that
I I'm happy to have it there's times
that I'm not I've had a lot of tractors
without it and it's the same thing right
it's it's a nice to have feature maybe
that's going to be dependent on what
your primary use is or your primary
function but either way it's a nice
option to have it is standard on the
summit tractor included in the base
price something minor and actually is
really not common on open station
tractors I don't know if it's available
from any manufacturer on an open station
tractor beside Summit but thinking more
along the lines of cab tractors because
um that seems to be what most folks are
emailed me about lately are going to be
mirrors on your calves all right and and
I don't think that those are standard
I'm sure there's some companies out
there that do have them standard but
make sure you ask the question uh
because it is annoying like I just
actually even I bought a Polaris Ranger
recently and my last
two utvs both had mirrors outside and it
must not have been an option because I
pretty much checked every option when I
was buying this thing and I don't have
mirrors on there and it annoys the heck
out of me every day so same concept with
the tractor especially a cab tractor
make sure you're getting the mirrors
added on I used to buy and sell a lot of
used tractors and and particular the cab
tractors I had many of them came in
without mirrors on there maybe they just
broke off but I'm thinking they're not
standard now the seat is an important
one you want a nice seat there's certain
series of tractors out there the John
Deere 3E series the John Deere 4M series
the Kubota standard L series for example
those are all
pretty basic tractor seats not a lot of
good suspension in there so some of the
more premium series attractors will have
a very nice suspension seat on there and
that's what's going to be included on
the summit tractor there's an upgrade
even from that on a lot of machines
which is going to be an air ride seat
and years ago my opinion has changed on
this I used to not think it was worth
the investment in that because it's not
a cheap upgrade I feel like it's a
thousand dollars or more to be honest
with you it's really expensive but
boy the more time I spend on tractors
the older I get the more I value comfort
and so that's where a really nice seat
and suspension comes into play and so if
you can get that upgrade I would
seriously consider it because you got to
remember you're hopefully not buying
this tractor just for right now but for
years down the road as well and it's
going to cost you more no doubt to
upgrade down the road than it is to just
do it right now okay a couple of points
to make down here and we talked about
this recently as well on a l6060 that my
buddy down the road is buying I love
these tires I absolutely love the
Goodyear Titan R14 tires I put them on
my John Deere 4 Series which has the
same tire size as the Kubota l6060 so if
your tractor dealer won't do it see if
they'll work with a local Tire Shop and
Swap those out for you you know I have
swapped out tires buying trucks from car
dealers even if they didn't carry those
tires or work with that brand it depends
on your dealer some dealer is going to
be better to work with than others
that's just the bricks of the game so
the Goodyear R14 is going to be a
available pretty much on on this size
machine here and on up the Carlisle
versaturf is what you're going to see on
the subcompact tractors your 1025rs your
Kubota BX a typical size is a 26 12 12
on the rears no matter which version
you're looking at they're going to be
taking the best of three different tread
patterns you're going to take the R1 AG
Tire like the old school Farm tires that
have the big V tread on there you're
going to take the R3 Turf Tire which is
obviously for Turf in a very
non-aggressive pattern and then the R4
industrial which is a thick bar Tire
it's the most common one that you see
out there in the tractor world today
kind of integrates all those together
and just makes a very good Traction Tire
for all different kinds of conditions so
if you're in mud if you're in snow if
you're on your lawn it's not going to
damage the lawn unless you're
doing something goofy to it you know
you're going to have the best chance for
Traction in those off-road conditions
and nasty conditions as well tires are
something you do not want to overlook
you really want to give it a lot of
thought and be a stickler about the
pattern that you want to get because
they're going to be very expensive to
change out later on and if you go with
the R1 AG tire for example if you want
to switch to an R14 or do an R4 down the
road you're likely going to have to
replace the wheels as well and so it
becomes even more expensive to do so and
the same thing can be said if you start
out with turfs on some tractors you're
going to have to get different Wheels to
go to the R14 or the R4 or anything else
so anyway these have been out for a
couple years now I think and so there's
a lot of reviews out there on them so
check the forums read tractor by net
make a post on Green Tractor Taco
whatever it is and get feedback on there
what other people are thinking you're
going to have folks always that say well
I don't know my whatever pattern works
great for me but it's a big investment
so just do your research all right so of
course you're not going to see the rim
guard liquid ballast or beet juice
inside these tires but this is a credit
critical ballast weight component and I
think something that virtually everybody
should get unless there's a real reason
not to have it tractors in general are
Tippy front to back okay so if you're
lifting a heavy load with your front end
loader the back end just normally does
not have enough weight so you need to
add more weight onto it a significant
amount a thousand pounds or more even
for a little compact tractor so if
you're new to our Channel I am a big
proponent of tractor safety I'd feel
guilty otherwise if I didn't preach
about it so I want you guys to be safe
out there get liquid ballast inside your
tires a great option to consider and
pretty much pretty much every tractor
dealer out there is going to offer some
form of liquid bells to put inside there
right up front so and some won't sell
without it all right some are not even
going to allow a tractor to go out their
door without liquid ballast in their
tires it's not going to help keep your
tractor planted to the ground but if
your tires are on the ground then you
have better traction right and you're
going to have better loader performance
so it's just a good thing all around add
more Bell switch to the back side to the
three-point hits when you can
wheel weights if you need to so the
summit tractor is going to be one of
those companies that comes standard with
rim guard inside the tires and we are
actually sponsored by rim guard that's
how serious I take tractor safety I want
everybody to know about it you know I
was just telling Chris I don't know how
the heck
there's a lot of dirt on this blower but
uh and I don't think I
I got it marked pretty good it must have
been dirt that's on the driveway but
it's all melting off now it's it's
supposed to be 50 degrees today
and uh middle of winter and go figure so
anyway next point
rear remotes all right so if you can get
every single remote you can that's what
I would do if you're if you're spending
50 60 70 grand on a tractor like a 4
series tractor costs these days then pay
the couple extra Grand or whatever it is
and get all the rear remotes on it that
you can get the the third function the
fourth function the fifth function the
power beyond just have it you're going
to be grateful at some point down the
road because a lot of the attachments
that you can get for it are going to
require extra Hydraulics or if you want
to get a top and a tilt kit that's two
hydraulic circuits right there I mean
they just add up very quickly
and I highly doubt you're going to
regret it so really quick what a rear
remote is this is a rear remote and this
is not two okay this is not two rear
remote this is one you have to have flow
that goes both ways hydraulic flow goes
in and out all right so if you have
you know I'll say this is a hydraulic
Chute rotation on this blower and you
push a lever that's up here on the
tractor you push the lever one way and
it sends a hydraulic fluid through all
the circuitry and everything and it
rotates the Chute One Way well hey guess
what now I want to rotate it back the
other way you pull the lever back the
other way and the flow is going to go
the opposite direction so that's one
circuit there that's tied up for that
hydraulic function so that's going to be
separate from the function that you have
up front as well all right so there's
that separate grapple function that's up
front sometimes called a third function
you're going to have your rear remote
now you're going to have mid remotes as
well you're going to have two of them
there in the mid remote switch kind of
think of that as the one and the two
scvs or selective control valves and so
two of those Outlets which is one remote
controls up and down on your front end
loader so you can't sacrifice that the
other two outlets which is the second
remote control the curl roll function of
your bucket and so that's why you need
something in addition up front to run
the grapple to open and close the jaws
of the grapple you still want to rock
and curl the grapple whether it's open
or closed so you need to have two
functions to open and close it and Rock
I can curl and then if you want to raise
and lower we're going to give it pinched
down and rock back that's the third
function there so you have to have those
three functions that all work in unison
up front you know and I would say
something like rear emotes gets easier
to justify with the more expensive of a
tractor that you're looking at now
probably the granddaddy of them all as
far as options go is going to be a
factory cab and so to me a factory cab
is one that it comes delivered to you
from the factory with the cab on it all
right and and it's going to have air
conditioning and heat it's going to be
just integrated right into the structure
the the the wraps bar is taken off and
the cab becomes your rollover protection
structure that's on there
that's something you cannot add on after
the fact and and yes Curtis does have a
cab an aftermarket cab with heat and air
that you can add to the Kubota BX line I
think it is but that's that's really
about the only thing and it's not going
to have the fit and finish unfortunately
like a true Factory cab is where it's
just it's like
structurally sound it doesn't rattle it
doesn't have that reverberation that
Echo chamber kind of feeling inside
there either it's just a really nice cab
but you're gonna paint
June hey hey
that's enough
hey
no thank you and I was reminded of that
wonderful convenience just recently when
I was blowing in a blizzard using this
snowblower right here and I um well I
was covered in snow by the end all right
it was like minus 11 wind chill the snow
was blowing all over the place and if
Summit had they're coming out with it
they're coming out with a factory cat
version but if they had the cat version
then you can sure bet I would have been
inside it but I wanted to give this
machine a shot using the snow blower and
see how it did and it worked well
but man it's hard to beat a cab not just
in the wintertime right for the the snow
and the cold and the wind and everything
else and just having that heat in there
but the same can be said for the
summertime with dust you know for for
allergies
um for bees and other bugs and stuff you
might get into that just sting you for
even the sun beating down on you it's
just nice to have the air conditioning
and be out of that nasty stuff that's
out there when you're brush hogging or
doing anything else so again one of the
main reasons that I chose to even
feature the summit tractor on my channel
is because of the good value that it is
and a lot of these options with other
manufacturers are standard on the summit
tractors the skid steer quick attach is
standard the third function is standard
the self-leveling loader is standard the
R14 tires are standard the rim guard is
standard the mirrors are standard the
rear remote is standard but no matter
what tractor you get make sure you have
it set up the right way don't have any
regrets so that's thousands of dollars
that come standard that are not going to
be an up charge compared to many other
brands out there so I thought it'd be a
good time to address summit's rollout
plan and you can get more information on
their website too but a lot of folks are
frustrated that they can't get a summit
tractor in their area or there's not a
servicing dealership OR technician in
their area right now and that is on
purpose all right this is a controlled
rollout where the Summit is
released and opened up and a certain
small segment right now to prove out
there all the Kinks in their system all
right and so they're to that point where
they're getting ready for that stage two
of the rollout and again you can look on
their website and see all the the
retailers where you're going to be able
to buy this either now or soon you know
coming spring of 2023 gonna be another
launch phase of this which is great and
they're going to have not only just the
retailers where you can buy the tractor
but they're also going to have the
locations on where you can have it
serviced too because that's the idea is
they don't want to sell these tractors
and just have them for sale all over the
country if they aren't yet set up and so
they're going through they've hired all
sorts of technicians they've trained
them they're to that point for the
distribution to scale that up and so
while frustration is never a good thing
um to me I I kind of view it as a good
thing just because there's a lot of
demand for the tractor out there so
that's a reassuring feeling to know but
I get where you're coming from as a
consumer if I see something and I want
to I want to buy it now as well but just
know that summit's looking at this from
the right right angle they don't want to
just get you a tractor say you're up in
Maine and they don't have anybody yet
that's servicing you they don't want to
sell you a tractor up there and not have
the service there available and ready to
support you if you need it so be patient
it's coming soon I promise just keep
tabs on their website Summit tractors
you'll get all the information you'll
need so that's going to do it for us
today if you did enjoy today's video you
want to see more about tractors in the
future as you start your tractor Journey
we'd love to have you tag along hit that
subscribe button right down below and if
you need an attachment for your tractor
we want to help you out we sell the ship
tractor attachments all over the country
every day of the week check out
goodworkstrackers.com if you don't need
an attachment but you still want to rock
some GWT swag check out our merchandise
it's all made to order it'll Ship Direct
right to you we don't keep any of those
profits they all get donated right to
charity thank you for taking time out of
your day to stop by and until next time
stay safe we'll see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]